ce centre de vaccination mosellan est
pris d'assaut depuis quelques jours la
faute à la propagation du variant sud
africain qui inquiète la population
je viens d'expliquer ça va très bien
mais alors quand on entend cette
histoire devant rien ces combats c'est
incroyable hélas là il ya eu un peu de
sa vie un peu doute 28 mille doses
supplémentaires vont être livrés en
moselle dans les deux prochaines
semaines et une opération exceptionnelle
a déjà été organisé ce week end pour
vacciner 2000 personnes nous avons
vacciné 274 personnes ce week end alors
que novak signons jusqu'à là à peu près
90 à 96 personnes un jour dorénavant
tout nouveau car entraîne un isolement
de dix jours du patient qui doit ensuite
fournir un test pcr négatif ces mesures
semblent être bien faible pour le maire
de metz il défend un confinement
localiser n'est pas seulement les bras
m'en tombent
on imaginait au moins avoir une réponse
positive sur la fermeture des
établissements scolaires une semaine
avant les vacances la propagation est
très importante chez les 10 20 ans mais
le gouvernement pratiquer la politique
de l'autruche
ce lundi la préfecture a lancé des
analyses des eaux usées elles ont été
confiées à une équipe spécialisée de
marins pompiers de marseille
le but réaliser une cartographie fine de
la diffusion des variants pour adapter
les mesures de riposte
en fait c'est quelque chose de très
précis vu que les gens qui sont positifs
contamine fatalement leur environnement
donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut retrouver
on peut aller jusqu'à la porte de la
personne de l'ehpad qui est positive
rien qu'avec de l'analyse de
prélèvements sur face à dunkerque c'est
le variant britannique qui est en cause
ici
le taux d'incidence c'est à dire le
nombre de nouveaux cas pour 100000
habitants sur sept jours et 2 500 soit
dix fois le seuil d alerte
le maire de la ville ne cache pas son
inquiétude aujourd'hui sur le territoire
dunkerquois nous avons à peu près 80% de
variants britannique dans l'es4
politique plus vite positif c'est comme
le variant britannique est très
contagieux il a fait exploser le nombre
de quatre colis 10,6 sur le territoire
dunkerquois et nous avons un hôpital qui
est aujourd'hui en saturation dix
patients été transféré la semaine passée
vers d'autres hôpitaux régionaux
contrairement à la demande des élus
locaux ici non plus les écoles ne
fermeront pas à une semaine des vacances
d'hiver
la préfecture du nord préfère que
l'arrivée des élèves se fasse de façon
décalée est une partie des cours aient
lieu en ligne